we can't do this to kits we're paying
far too much money for a public
education system that isn't working I'm
Andrew Campanella vice president of
national school choice week national
school choice week is about offering
solutions school choice access to better
options empowering parents and kids and
transforming a system away from being an
adult jobs program about buildings about
bureaucracies and into about educating
the next generation of kids who can get
the best jobs I think that our team is
most excited about seeing so many
different very diverse events all across
the country New Orleans has more
educational opportunities for parents
than almost any other city in America
parents here are not trapped by sending
their kids just to one school based on a
zip code so if a parent doesn't make a
lot of money and can't afford a private
school they can access the scholarship
public charter schools are thriving here
public schools are improving there are
virtual schools magnet schools and
enhanced options for homeschooling so
New Orleans really provides a true menu
of options for families and that's why
we decided that this is one of the best
places to kick off national school
choice week I think that it shows the
true resiliency of folks here in New
Orleans to come through something like
Katrina and then tackle the issue of
education reform rebuilding a school
system and rebuilding it right so what
we've seen is a community truly come
together and build what could be a model
system for the rest of the country
focused on choice giving parents the
opportunities to access any number of
different options we see competition
enter the marketplace schools competing
to get kids their students achieving and
people like going to school here what
we'd love to see is cities across the
country model their education system
focused around choice on what we see
here in New Orleans now are the results
perfect no but there's a lot of
different options that parents can
choose if they're not happy compare that
to a system where a parent has one
school to send their child they are
trapped they have no way to get out and
what we as a country have been trained
to tell parents for years and years is
that to just wait five or ten years for
your local public school to improve
imagine if you went to a car dealership
when your car was broken and someone
said to you like it's going to take five
or ten years
for us to fix your engine how irate you
would be but that's what we're telling
parents all across the country today
kids are a lot more important than cars
and it's time to start treating them
with more seriousness than we treat our
automobiles the American Dream is going
to be completely lost to other countries
if we don't fix our education system now
other countries are not just nipping at
our heels educationally they've lapped
us we're 35th in the world in math and
literacy we cannot afford the high costs
of low achievement in this nation
me